a timely ill man has been given a chance
of life after doctors replaced his heart
with the genetically modified pigs
a warning this report from our u.s
correspondent greg milam includes
pictures of the operation from the start
this is the heart that could give hope
to hundreds of thousands of people
around the world in a baltimore
operating theater the organ taken from a
pig about to be transplanted into the
body of david bennett the 57 year old
handyman was ineligible for a human
heart transplant his own heart failing
and so ill he told his surgeon he was
willing to give the experimental
procedure a try and perhaps make history
he simply didn't want to die
doesn't want to die
and
he felt that if he had no opportunity
and he was pretty well convinced by
multiple doctors who had told him he had
a fatal disease and he was unlikely to
leave the hospital because of it
attempts at transplants like this have
failed in the past because the patient's
body rejects the animal organ this time
the pig had been genetically modified to
lower the chances of that happening he's
awake he is
recovering and speaking to his
caregivers and
we hope
that the recovery that he is having now
will continue
and four days after it began beating
inside mr bennett it is still going he's
now breathing on his own it is a game
changer because
you know now
we will have these organs readily
available if this works and you know and
i hope it will work
doctors say the next few weeks will be
critical for mr bennett and for whether
a quest that's gone on for decades
finding an answer to the chronic
shortage of human organs for transplant
could at last be solved
they say this is a first tentative step
but one towards the day when the world
isn't limited by the supply of human
organs and an end to the years those
waiting have to endure greg milam sky
news los angeles